welcome to another edition of a
Scholastic checkmates I'm your host 1998
Missouri Scholastic champion Michael
come on
all right in this game we have a
checkmate on the board can we see it
I'll give you a hint it's black to move
in checkmate all right if you haven't
seen it now's the time Queen the c5
checkmate you see how the Queen is
protecting the rook through an x-ray
Kings cannot capture protected pieces as
a bishop is protecting it
unfortunately Aditi did not see this
checkmate so it continues moving farther
into the action here we go do you see a
checkmate on the board a dethie got so
excited about discovered checks
she put her bishop on c7 you know who
she actually should have put on c7 the
Queen yes very wet all right
progressing further into the action
notice now a DP has taken all the pawns
one with her King as well everybody can
get into the melee now she has made in
one but she decides for the mate in for
checkmate and that is another edition of
scholastic checkmate